[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
that was low energy hello and welcome to
dear Hank and John doors I prefer to
think of a Dear John and Hank it's a
comedy podcast at which two brothers
answer your question can be devious
advice and bring you all the week's news
from both Mars and AFC Wimbledon John
Green how are you doing I mean no John
what is the elephant in the room all
right are you ready three two one
man old and state killer so my elephant
in the room is man hole Hank in last
week's pod you suggested that a really
excellent name for a pet would be man
hole I put you under a lot of pressure
to come up with 20 good pet names in 20
seconds and you came up with seven and I
thought you were gonna crush it but then
you came up with man hole which was
pretty disappointing except that several
people were inspired to name their own
pets man hole including Abbi who wrote
in Dear John and Hank I'd like to
introduce you to man hole or Manny for
short an adorable little kitten she also
signed off she's not to che be really
good name specific sign off a B also
Jack wrote in to introduce us to his
fish man hole and Anna went so far as to
rename her 15 year old cat who had
previously been named Kasper which is a
perfectly reasonable cat name but is now
named man hole which I'm sure your 15
year old cat will be very grateful for
and I'm sure that that's gonna be a
highlight being suddenly renamed in the
last presumably few years of your life
and like the gold in the twilight years
if your cat's life is just like wait
what it's always been it's always been
my hope to retire and be renamed manhole
well you know John you could do that
right now you could just be done and all
you gonna do is podcast with me and
that's it yeah welcome to dear Hank and
manhole
I would not be done just for the record
my retirement does not involve
podcasting with you every week well then
do not retire
Hank why
is the Golden State killer the elephant
in the room I don't listen to many true
crime podcasts or consume much true
crime content I don't really like it it
gives me the heebie-jeebies but I do
follow a number of people on Twitter who
are super into true crime including
people who who are kind of into it
professionally and do that for a living
and the Golden State killer is a guy who
killed a bunch of people more than a
decade ago I don't know how many more
than it Oh like I was like that forty
years ago and as a result of Michelle
McNamara's and her colleagues work at
least in part the Golden State killer
has been arrested just this morning as
we're recording this he is a 72 year old
man today but more than 40 years ago he
began attacking women and is been
responsible for several murders and many
more assaults and has been captured
today it is an incredible story that
this 40-year search for a criminal has
finally come to an end so
congratulations to everybody who's
worked so hard on that to all the
law-enforcement people involved on
closing that case and that very dark
chapter in California history Hank Cobb
and John thank you for knowing a lot
more about my elephant than I did I just
it was just on my it's just trending on
Twitter and that's all I knew oh yeah I
have you know I haven't been on Twitter
today how's it been um I'd figured out
how to tweet nothing
oh well that that is a huge development
John how are things going good over the
John green world yes I'm just back from
London where I spent a few days with my
son in London it was his first
international trip since we lived for a
few months in Amsterdam when he was 1
and we had a great time we had a really
really lovely time together and he got
to have a really special visit to AFC
Wimbledon which is something that he's
been looking forward to for a long time
as a member of the Dons Junior trust
which any
I'll to conjoin it's only like $25 a
year it's so great to be a co-owner of
this wonderful community owned fan fan
based club and Hank Henry had a really
wonderful special day he got to meet a
bunch of the players they signed a ball
for him it was really really wonderful
but we'll get to all of that during the
news from AFC Wimbledon Hank we need to
get a speaking of true crime to our
first question
oh this question comes from Herbie who
asks Dear John and Hank do dead bodies
get sunburned not planning anything
Herbie
thank you for the clarification Harvey
yeah otherwise we would have thought
that you were planning anything just
kidding Herbie that's what people who
are planning things say they say they're
not planning anything John you might be
surprised to learn that I did a bunch of
research on whether the dead bodies get
sunburned I didn't have to do research
on it because I was just in the British
Museum where I saw a heavily sunburned
dead body just sitting there in the
middle of the museum and they were like
look at this mummy he dried out in the
Sun and we know how he died and I was
trying to shield Henry from it but Henry
was like oh wow that is amazing and good
and Henry was like he died of a shoulder
wound he got stabbed by a long knife and
I was like great I'm glad glad that we
know this much about this eight thousand
year old man and I'm sure that he would
be absolutely delighted to find himself
dried and sunburned in the British
Museum can dead bodies get sunburned
Hank they can get damaged by the Sun but
a sunburn is a pretty specific set of
things that happen and it is it is not
just the damage that is done in fact
like basically what happens is your
cells get damaged by the Sun and then
your body has a reaction and in flames
that area to do to do the repair work
and a lot of times that is actually the
thing that is causing discomfort is the
inflammation of the repair rather than
the damage itself but the damage itself
also can cause a lot of problems and
depending on how severe it is so yeah
it's the the cells can get damaged and
they can get damaged whether or not they
are alive and actually like
interestingly cells continue to like do
some metabolizing stuff after the the
what we would consider the death so they
can the the individual cells will
continue to be alive even after the
person is dead and so you can you could
still get some of that inflammation you
could get some of that even some like
melanin production so you would get a
very even tiny amount of tanning that
would happen after the body died but
only for a very short amount of time
well I am glad that I know that I feel
that my life has been enriched almost as
much as if I had learned how to tweet
nothing I I gotta keep working on how to
done tweeting nothing John I but I mean
wouldn't it be amazing if we all just
started tweeting nothing
wouldn't it be as just like suddenly my
timeline was just like for an entire day
nothing just tweeting but there was
nothing in the tweets baby we know maybe
there should be a holiday we should make
that happen are we powerful enough to
create a day on which people just tweet
nothing how powerful are we are we there
yet
because that's really the goal first off
we're on the other side of the mountain
so when you say are we there yet it
implies that we're about to become more
famous when in fact we will just become
slowly less and less powerful over the
next several decades which I would argue
as welcome news the people who have
replaced us are far better on every
level secondly no we are not even close
to powerful enough to have a site-wide
day of tweeting nothing No
and then just everybody responds to each
other with nothing and then like this
more nothing and everybody likes each
other's tweets and retweets nothing I
don't know John see the thing we are
we're not getting we're not getting more
popular fewer people are knowing who we
are agreed but what if we're getting
more influential because the people who
do know who we are are getting really
good jobs in like
managing social media celebrity accounts
just let the first huh you think the
person who's tweeting for Kanye right
now is a nerdfighter yeah who knows I
mean whoever's tweeting for Kanye just a
quick word of advice stop tweet nothing
tweet nothing and maybe in fact that's
good advice for all of us
I find myself less and less interested
in Twitter it might interest in Twitter
is limited almost exclusively to your
podcast delete this well it's it is
probably the best way to consume Twitter
it only takes an hour of your life every
week and you don't have to be on Twitter
yeah it's been great so far I've really
enjoyed it
Hank why don't you has another question
this question comes from Sarah who asks
dear Hank and John I've heard that
newborns think that their mother's body
is just part of their own body how do we
know what babies think how do you
science a baby que sera sera I don't
know that we know that much about what
babies think Sarah but we know that even
like four-year-olds still sort of think
of their mothers as an extension of
their bodies here's a really weird thing
John I realized you know a few months
into my child being born and like he
like when he came when he was like a
suddenly new Pete person in the world it
was like yes this was created entirely
by Kathryn this was a construction
completely of things that Kathryn did
which is remarkable but then he's gotten
like doubled in size he's starting to do
things and smile and interact and still
though he's still entirely Kathryn
because at that point he'd only ever had
breast milk in his real life baby is an
entire like so in a way yes they may be
do they think that they're part of their
mother's body I'm taking that question
and I'm discarding it for a second to
say they are like physically everything
that was him up to like eight months old
maybe not that long I don't know when he
had his first banana I've licked his
first piece of bacon or whatever but for
long time there was this human that was
entirely constructed out of things
Catherine had eaten right it is weird
no the more you think about babies the
weirder they get the more you think
about human life in general the weird or
just life in general I think about
babies is like it's the most natural
thing like of course like there is no
biology there are no humans without
babies that's the whole point is to
reproduce that's how biology works well
it's not the whole point sorry I don't
need to say that in terms of like it's
the whole point of life it's certainly
not the whole point of life but it is
like like in terms of evolution in terms
of how like the sort of physical
constraints of biology it does not
function without reproduction but it
seems like the weirdest thing despite it
being like literally the only necessary
part of life right if you're trying to
explain reproduction to an alien planet
that didn't have life the way that we
have it they would be like what why how
why do you have why do the babies come I
don't know just the parents why wait why
why do they have to eat part of the
parents body to survive that's terrible
it's like there's a great very short
science fiction story that I'm going to
butcher in the way of these things that
talks about trying to introduce humans
to an alien like bureaucracy like
explaining what kind of organism they
are and the bureaucrat is explaining to
their boss that humans are essential
species that is entirely made out of
meat I've heard the story and the boss
like what like even their thinking parts
meet they're all meat no we're just a
bunch of just a bunch of collections of
meat really deep down that's all we are
so yes yeah there's a there's a YouTube
video of it which is what I've seen it's
called they're made out of meat and
they're like
sitting in a gimmick like a diner a
roadside diner and the guys like what
they're made of meat yeah so there you
go
it's not just that babies think of their
mothers as an extension of their body in
a way we're all extensions of each
other's bodies
and we're all really where I intended to
go from the beginning with this question
we think that we're separate organisms
but oh we are not no it's the more you
think about it the grosser and weirder
it gets let's move on to another
question are you too upset John I just I
really like the idea as you know Hank of
being a sovereign being separate from
other beings that has its own
independent existence and life and I
just can't be that because I am super
saturated with bacteria and then also
made out of meat that is made out of
other people anyway this next question
comes from Alice who writes Dear John
and Hank I was just listening to your
most recent episode and really enjoyed
the discussion about dates of book
releases and how John was denied the
ability to choose his own release date
because all books come out on Tuesday so
I wanted to let you in on a
not-so-secret secret James Patterson is
the only author whose books come out on
a day other than Tuesday all of his
books come out on Monday instead I'm a
cataloging librarian who processes all
of the new books that are library
purchases so I see many new release
books DVDs etc they all come out on
Tuesday except for James Patterson just
James Patterson has to do is become
James Patterson and then he can choose
whichever day of the week you want
publishes books on like Wonderland Alice
is it possible yeah that James Patterson
all powerful force in the world could
make all of Twitter tweet nothing for a
day because clearly he has some power
that we do not have can I tell you a
joke that my uncle bill I guess also
your uncle bill told me that I just
found absolutely hilarious yeah you
should've just have my own
so we could continue the conspiracy
theory that were not actually related
right so your uncle bill told me this
joke I found it very enjoyable joke goes
like this John Grisham calls up James
Patterson one afternoon and James
Patterson's wife answers and John
Grisham says is James there and
Patterson's wife says he is but I'm
afraid he's working on a book would it
be okay if he called you back and John
Grisham says I'll hold only takes James
Patterson like 10 minutes to write a
book yeah he must be probably you know
on average halfway through so it'll be
five minutes right right so James
Patterson gets to publishes books on
Monday because he's James Patterson and
like two-thirds of the overall sales
this book come out not sales just the
total books that hit the shelves are
James Patterson books at any given
moment half of Barnes and Noble is James
Patterson and the other half is the rest
of us so I just wanted to let you know
about that ank in case you want to
change the release date of your
forthcoming novel and absolutely
remarkable thing which is currently
scheduled to come out on a Tuesday but
maybe you need to call the mask from the
Patterson treatment well it is Monday is
the day to do it cuz when I was thinking
about this when I was real if fitting to
our podcast which I don't usually do but
I did with the last podcast it was
really good I enjoyed it we did a good
job and thinking about this that like
okay you can't come out on Wednesday cuz
they're gonna open the box early but you
could come out on Monday because they'll
open the box and if they do if they
forget then well it's a day late and
everybody's in there in there being like
you ready to open the James Patterson
box and yeah and you're getting it's
it's more good publicity for you cuz
people are tweeting about it well there
you go like you certainly can't come out
on Wednesday that's just ludicrous
you've just had the revelation that
James Patterson had 25 years ago and
that is the sole reason that he has
become the most successful author in the
United States there must be like a
bulwark against the second author being
added to
Monday list because it would ruin
everything and suddenly it'd be like
well I'm a Tuesday author so I'm not a
big deal but like if it's just James
Patterson you know that like well I'm
not James Patterson but if it's like
five people you're like well why am I
not one of those five people publisher
and then you're writing it into your
contract and you're feeling hurt when
you come your book comes out on Tuesday
you're not a real author you're a
Tuesday author all of this reminds me of
how much publishing and so much of life
in adulthood is identical to middle
school I'm the Tuesday author John and
I'm happy just like I was happy to be a
complete social outcast of middle school
that's a lie it was miserable
it was terrible I mean I felt terrible
for you but I felt worse for myself when
it was happening to me all right John
this K this question is very peripheral
real very related it's from Emily who
asks dear Hank and job dude to the soon
due to the upcoming release of Avengers
event infinity war in the press tour
that's happening I've started to ask
myself about Fame what exactly is the
reason I want to watch every interview
with Benadryl come Q Cumberbatch I
didn't I did not notice that the first
of her through the question so it's a
bit of a surprise
benadryl cucumber patch I understand
that personal reaction to Fame is very
subjective and based on my interests if
I met a famous soccer player I'd be like
wow that's a famous person but I
wouldn't freak out why do we respond to
the constructive quote unquote fame like
this and when did it start who are the
first fans that's a fascinating question
looking forward to learning more and
Hanks novel an absolutely remarkable
thing it's available to September 25th
and you can get it for pre-order now
signed on books-a-million Barnes and
Noble and amazon.com
dftba Emily also signed copies will be
available at your local independent
bookstore Emily but to get to your
question I think Fame is really weird
and I think the way that we worship it
is really weird and I'm saying this
genuinely I have never read as
convincing or compelling a portrayal of
Fame and the ways that it can be both
addictive and corrosive as Hanks novel
it is so smart in the way it writes
about that stuff in the way that it
looks at it through the lens of this
young woman who becomes initially
somewhat famous and then wildly famous
as a result of her discovering these
corals or I guess just one of the corals
but the thing that gets me about Hank's
book that I keep coming back to and I
think I mean I first read it like six
months ago and I the reason I can't stop
thinking about it is because this young
woman can't stop making compromises with
herself to continue to become more
famous even though she recognizes pretty
early on that she doesn't actually want
to become more famous and that really
resonates with me not only because my
personal experience but also because of
the people I've had around me who were
far more famous that than I was and and
seeing the difficulties that they went
through I just think it's a brilliant
book I really do I'm really excited for
people to read it but because of that
that was very kind john will just take
that put that whole thing on the back
cover of the book and everybody was very
happy available September 25th I've been
thinking a lot about specifically so
there's this this sort of out of vogue
idea in psychiatry and psychology that
there there are these fundamental fears
and there's only three of them and I
can't remember all three of them at the
moment but one of them is the fear of
being negatively judged and I I think
that we are also like very driven by
other people's opinions of us and it's
very hard once you start to have like a
lot of people having opinions about you
it's almost that the quantity of
opinions is superior to the quality of
whatever opinion is happening to be had
so a lot of people would almost rather
have people think things about them at
all than to have people think positive
things about them and that's not like
that's not I think actually that
irrational of a response because we like
our society values
you know influence like our society
values power and I think that just like
our brains value power because
ultimately you want to be in a place
where you can say okay
September 25th is know tweet day I don't
want to be in that place I have to say I
don't I don't buy that because I
genuinely don't want to have write power
right I think that power should be
vested in one person I think that power
invested in institutions and I think the
worship of individuals and individual
power is a big part of the problem that
we find ourselves in but I think that
it's this it's the simple way to imagine
things and so when you don't have a lot
of direct experience with it which most
people don't like you I think that it is
very common for people to sort of feel
like ah that's very appealing that's
very exciting and imagine what it would
be like to be Kim Kardashian and and I
think that that sort of bears out in the
popularity of Kim Kardashian like people
are excited about her because of her
influence and and sort of like imagining
imagining that in a sort of hashtag
goals kind of way right thing is that I
don't think Kim Kardashian actually has
that much power right there's this run
the jewels lyric that goes like who
really runs this like who really runs
that man that says he runs this and to
me that's the truth that beneath the
individuals who feel that they are
wielding power or who we feel our
wielding power is a much larger power
system that we don't look at very
carefully because we're so concerned
with the individuals rather than with
the system that produces them and pushes
them and they do that direction
yeah like literally no one is powerful
enough to create no tweet day no one can
do that and like that that in itself
that sort of says says something very
interesting about how we imagine power
and how we imagine power acting upon us
that like in some ways there is a force
but that force is not controlled by any
individual and any like even close to
any individual and so all of these
all societal changes have to happen
slowly because there is no one who is
making these decisions consciously to
Emily's question I am curious who were
the first fans John who were the front
like was it like you
Kalitta DS who's Euclid it ease I made
it up I was trying to come up with like
a playwright oh that's good yeah I mean
play early playwrights had fans I think
that for we don't know because I think
that way we have of giving power and
influence to individuals even though in
many ways those individuals are only
expressing the whims of much larger
forces that are bigger than any of us I
think that goes all the way back I think
that goes back to the earliest human
communities it's just that those early
human communities were you know a few
dozen or a few hundred people big and so
it wasn't as widespread there wasn't
global fame until you know I don't know
the 18th or 19th century we got another
question John that I really think we
need to focus on here it's from Mara who
asks dear Hank and John my boyfriend's
mom and stepdad recently bought a home
and have subsequently acquired 500
bottles of the previous owners homemade
wine they tried a bottle and the wine
wasn't very I'm just gonna stop reading
this question right now you gotta throw
that wine away you might die you might
kill somebody if you sell it on
Craigslist you got four hundred
ninety-nine bottles of poison yeah first
off how bold a person do you have to be
to open up someone else's homemade wine
like do you know what happened to that
person do you know how you came to own
this property is it possible that you
came to own this property because they
died of homemade wine poisoning yeah or
or they had to flee the country because
their homemade wine killed someone or
they killed someone and put them in the
homemade wine there are so many
terrifying possibilities get rid of that
homemade wine I think I don't know about
this but I made homemade wine once oh I
bet I bet you did Winsor and I lived in
New York we spent an exorbitant amount
of money on a homemade wine kit and I'm
not
sure what I thought was gonna happen
because I should have known such a
beautiful picture you and Sara and like
your tiny apartment in New York to be
like we're gonna be vinter sense totally
what we were thinking 600 square feet
and ready for commercial wine production
and you know I made like one 5-gallon
jug of wine and it was so incredibly bad
and I just remember thinking to myself I
spent $400 on this one incredibly bad
five-gallon bucket of wine I will never
ever engage in any kind of and how was
it gardening or horticulture ever again
it was so bad I mean it tasted enough
like grape juice because it was the
alcohol content was way lower than it
should have been it tasted enough like
grape juice that I did eventually work
my way through the entire five gallons
but only because I knew that it had cost
me 400 freakin dollars well you know
five gallons of wine is a lot I my
experience with homemade wine is that
people bring it over to your house and
then you you say to yourself I wish I
was drinking real wine even three dollar
wine now of course I don't want to hurt
the feelings of all the hardcore
homemade wine people out there I'm sure
that your homemade wine is great but do
not bring it to my house yeah I don't
trust you let's be honest I don't trust
you to create something that I enjoy the
flavor of it I don't trust you not to
kill me John I have an important update
I said vinter when I was talking about
someone who makes wine yeah it is in
fact vintner and I would like you to
know and I typed in vinter into the
Google and the first thing that came up
it says noun winter the coldest of the
four seasons no way it does I think it's
a different language maybe no way that's
what it says winter the coldest of the
four seasons on Wiktionary you know it
does it does it's Danish Hank yeah I've
been a Danish speaker this whole time
it's the Danish Norwegian and
Swedish word for winter so there you go
all right Hank let's get to this
question from Carly who writes dear
chowder Nick my friends snapchat and
Drive they snapped themselves talking
into the camera singing to the radio or
they just snap a video of the dashboard
because they like the song on the radio
obviously this is dangerous but I
haven't managed to convince anyone that
they're doing anything wrong driving
feel safe even though it is the most
dangerous thing people do every day how
do I get through to my friends before
they kill us all
Wonderwall and Rex Carly Carly there
need to be more people in the world like
you who are afraid of the things that we
should be afraid of and not afraid of
the things that we shouldn't be afraid
of like shark attacks or whatever I have
blogged while driving I feel terrible
about it I feel like I made a terrible
terrible example that other people might
have followed and thereby endangered
their lives it's not a funny business it
is so incredibly serious one of the very
few ways in which life is getting worse
for humans in 2018 is that the number of
motor vehicle accidents leading to
serious injury and death in the United
States is not dropping even though our
cars are getting safer and the reason
it's not dropping is because of
distracted driving yeah I mean like I
don't I don't know if there's a way to
sort of like do it in a way that isn't
super confrontational and doesn't drive
people to defensiveness will they be
where they sort of like like get even
more tied in to their bad way of
behaving if there's some kind of like
basically meme that you can create among
your friends that like you are the
person who cares about this and you're
going to give them a hard time about it
every single time and that's because you
love them if there's like you're just
gonna you basically you draw like a
Tyrannosaurus Rex
yeah and he's called he's called snappy
that don't snap all you're driving t-rex
yep and you and you take a picture and
send that to them every time and you say
I'm not every time you get a snappy I'm
not talking to you for a day there's no
more snap chatting and I'm sewing by the
fact that you're using snapchat that you
are under the age of 25
and so everyone your snapchatting with
is fairly new to the whole driving thing
and that is when a lot of accidents
happen when people are fairly new the
driving thing you start to think that
you're pretty good at it but it turns
out that you haven't experienced a lot
of the things that you might experience
the sort of out cut outside edge cases
of of traffic unfortunate Nasseri bad
and and like a legitimate cause of
tremendous amount of tragedy and pain in
the world and so I think that like if
you can put together a good old snappy
the t-rex don't snap while you're
driving t-rex
picture please do that do I have the
power to do that at least John probably
although I think that your understanding
of both teen culture and meme culture
are pretty weak but I like the idea of
snappy the t-rex it doesn't seem at all
like a cringy thing invented by a 38
year old to keep the young people from
distracted driving it doesn't seem like
that at all it seems like people are
totally gonna respond to that they're
gonna be like oh wow I got a snappy the
t-rex I'm in big trouble
John this is how it happens this is how
terrible ideas occur but I swear if
actual if an actual teen does this and
it's their idea not mine it will be
super cool right yes it will be super
cool Carly I actually think that's a
pretty good idea which speaks to the
fact that I'm even older than Hank and I
guess there is an off chance that you
are yourself our age Carly in which case
your friends have two problems one they
shouldn't be snapchatting that is for
young people and two they shouldn't be
driving while distracted but anyway all
of that reminds me Hank that today's
podcast is brought to you by our
number-one most important sponsor snappy
the t-rex
snappy the t-rex reminding you not to
snap while driving is snap the right
verb for snapchatting I don't even know
yes not to snap while driving since 2018
and 5s was also brought to you by James
Patterson's tweet nothing des ursins
working together with social media
celebrities across the world including
the nerdfighter who runs Kanye West's
twitter account to create a day in which
no one tweet
anything but you do tweet something it's
just nothing's in the tweets and of
course the days but Gus is brought to
you by 499 bottles of probably poisonous
homemade wine not for sale and finally
this podcast is made out of newborn
babies they're made out of mom all right
you didn't say sponsored by you said
this podcast was made out of newborn
babies but whatever I like it I think I
said we had you're pretty sleep-deprived
because you have a young child so it's
kind of true and I like it we also have
a project for awesome message
Alex donated to the project for awesome
so that we would read this message to
Tommy you are an amazing person and your
friends and family know it they all love
you I love you never forget that there
is a small chance that I mispronounced
Tommy in which case some of the like
moving neces would get lost so in case
it's I'm just gonna hope that it's Tommy
good John
also John we are putting together a dear
Hank and John survey there's a link to
it in the show notes if you like dear
Hank and John we want to learn a little
bit more about you and also what you'd
like us to do on the podcast and the
other things that you might be into so
if you could go to the show notes and I
don't really know how show notes work
but whatever app you're using there's
probably a thing there and there will be
a link there and you can use that it's
surveymonkey.com slash are slash dhj
survey 2018 it's super easy to remember
URL this is not like one of those
annoying surveys that other podcasts
make you take where they only ask
questions about how to market more
effectively to you this is a survey
where we ask questions about how to
market more effectively to you and also
other things yes thank yous to take the
survey if you have a chance it is really
really helpful for us to understand who
you are and what stuff you're into what
you like about the pod what you don't
like what you'd like to see more of and
less of that sort of thing okay John
this
question comes from Mark who asks dear
Hank and John so what do you do when
you're mad crushing on somebody who
lives a long way away is it better to be
honest stay as friendly correspondents
or just we is it is it better to be
honest stay as friendly correspondents
or just wean off communication to save
yourself some heartache P&P
mark what's P and P Pride and Prejudice
I assume so but it could also be Proctor
and Proctor a new and exciting new
multinational corporation it could refer
to one of the world's largest golf cart
dealerships PNP golf carts it could
refer to PNP home services with urban
dictionary P and P means party and play
which is about sex stuff and meth why
did you trick us mark the rest of your
question was pretty normal and then you
made a mess thing God as if we weren't
already old enough Hank after inventing
snappy the anti distracted driving t-rex
good lord I mean I think that in general
when the love compounds start flowing in
our brains and we start to feel really
attached and and just that that's a lot
it's a lovely feeling but I think that
our brains can start doing a lot of
tricks to make us think that a thing is
possible and it may not be possible I
don't I feel bad about saying this but
starts doing all kinds of weird
gymnastics and like your brain turns
into like like spinny flippy simone
biles trying to convince you how you're
gonna make this work i disagree with
everything that you just said except for
the fact that simone biles is really
good at flipping which she is fantastic
at she's an amazing amazing athlete but
the rest of what you said i'd completely
disagree with it is totally possible to
have a fulfilling long-distance
relationship and if that relationship
doesn't
doesn't have a relationship yet this
person is crushing on somebody who's a
long way away right so I'm saying to if
you want to tell the person that you
want to be in a long-distance
relationship with them tell them that
and see how it goes and if it doesn't
work out and so whatever such as life
but if it does work out that's great I
know that I'm a big defender of
long-distance relationships because I
had a really fulfilling one when I was
in college but I don't think there's
anything wrong with them so that's my
advice mark just communicate that's Kate
is good 99% of these questions could be
answered with the word communicate
followed by an exclamation point that's
a good shirt we should make that shirt
the other 1% of questions can be
answered of course with snappy the t-rex
this next question comes from Fras write
Dear John and Hank I'm currently sitting
in the middle seat of an airplane using
my 15 minutes of free plane Wi-Fi to ask
you an incredibly pressing question
shortly after takeoff the people on
either side of me fell asleep wasting
both the view and the clear access to
the bathroom for the foreseeable future
the attendants have just started serving
the food and my question is can I take
the subpar food that was meant for them
thanks Fras no don't take strangers food
from them they could wake up at any
moment
no we're gonna have to disagree again I
see are you you're gonna you're gonna
steal a stranger's food well I'll tell
you didn't even buy their house and
inherit it I'll tell you a story about
five days ago I was flying on a plane
with my son
to London and they wake you up even
though I didn't really sleep that well
because you know I was on a plane with
my son they wake you up and they give
you breakfast right but Henry didn't
want to wake up which credit to him he
was trying to get a full night's sleep
on the six-hour red-eye flight and so it
was like this I don't I don't even know
how you say this right is it like acai
acai acai you know those things oh the
little berries yeah there's like very
bowls it was one of those one of those
bowls and I ate it it didn't even I he
wasn't awake it doesn't he doesn't care
he's no his son this is a person you
have a relationship with you steal his
food all the
I steal his food yeah a little bit
know each other it's a little bit
different but I don't think it's that
different I if the person look if the
food's just sitting there just just eat
it real quick you're in the middle seat
you're suffering you're going through a
hard time
yeah well it depends like if it's like a
if it's like a bisque off cracker or a
bag of pretzels maybe but if it's like a
tray with dinner on it you can't start
picking off their tray yeah yeah I don't
know bag of president I feel like an ass
I are a chi or whatever that is one of
those bowls that's that's that sort of
it in between place yeah take the whole
bowl and it's like oh they just gave me
two they didn't give you one I got three
of them and you two didn't get any I
don't know what happened that's what I
actually did I stack the bowls but he'd
never notice till he listens to the pod
that is all right Nick we need to get to
the all-important news from Mars and AFC
Wimbledon what is the news from Mars
this week you know how Mars has two real
good moons yes top-notch moons your
Phobos and Deimos are Mars is to two
good old moons they're smaller than our
moon they're sort of lumpy and potatoey
because they're not big enough to have
formed themselves into Spears when they
were forming mm-hmm and and there's a
lot of sort of question about how they
formed and some people think that they
were just captured asteroids because
they look like asteroids they're the
size of some asteroids and the shape of
asteroids but and we to be clear we will
know this for sure in like 2029 when I
think that the Japanese Space Agency is
sending a mission to one of those two
moons I couldn't tell you which one
taking a sample and sending it back it's
a lot easier to send back a sample from
Phobos or Deimos because there's so
light that the return trip is actually
pretty easy because you don't have to
escape a gravity well really and yeah so
they're gonna like we'll be able to
analyze a piece of one of these moons
which will tell us basically everything
we ever wanted to know so but at the
moment it remains a mystery
but there probably aren't captured
asteroids which was our theory for a
long time hmm because they they both are
in they rotate around Mars
at Mars's equator which would be a
really weird coincidence if they were
captured asteroids they also rotate in a
way that like would be it would very
strange for them to be in such such like
non elliptical orbits their orbits are
pretty circular if they were captured
asteroids and also there have been some
computer models that say like if this
thing if you capture these moons that
way they would be ripped apart by the
tidal forces of being captured in Mars's
gravity so the the new theory was that
like Mars was hit just like Earth was
and early in the solar system's
formation by a giant impactor of some
kind and that threw off some stuff
around Mars that eventually coalesced
into these moons and that impactor was
pretty big in our former models but a
new paper just came out and it says that
that impactor probably didn't have to be
nearly as big as we thought it had to be
in order for it to throw up the amount
of stuff that ended up in Phobos and
Deimos so there's a new study basically
that says yes it's likely and very
probable that it was that these moons
were caused by an object not even that
big of an object certainly big win by
global scale catastrophe but not like
the object that hit us that formed our
Moon and and when was like less than 1%
of the mass of Mars that was able to
create these moons but we won't know
that for sure until hopefully the early
2008 2020 is early 2030s when we start
to analyze some actual pieces of these
Martian moons whenever I think about the
fact that our moon and potentially these
two moons as well were formed by
asteroids that led to a huge chunk of
the planet entering the orbit of the
planet yeah I am reminded of how
stupidly unlikely life as we know it is
[Music]
well may be true it may not be I don't
know obviously we've only got a sample
size of one right now in terms of
planets that have life on them but but I
think there's a lot to be said for the
possibility that life could be
not as rare as we think it's not really
in this it was very early in the solar
system that this happened and basically
earth was hit by basically a planet
another planet hit us right and that's
like it'd be I mean like what if like
the thing I think about it's like all
the different ways the dice could have
rolled and we could have ended up with
very easily two planets very close to
each other both with a lot of water both
with a lot of like good gasses that
would be conducive to life and we could
have ended up in a solar system where
life happened twice in a very big way
the way that it happened on earth and
that would have been a very different
trajectory when we were like early when
we first were trying to figure out Mars
and we could get in telescopes they
could see it pretty well we were
starting to think like this probably
life on that planet but it turned out
when we went there was not but what if
we had gone and there was I would have
been so deeply different a future for
Humanity it would have been but in a way
we experienced that in the Columbian
Exchange because there were two worlds
that had very that had a few connecting
points obviously over the course of the
last 250,000 years but that that were
pretty separate for a lot of human
history and then we discovered that
there was essentially you know a second
half of the world whether that second
half was you know afro-eurasia or the
Americas depending on your defendant of
course on where you were when it
happened but yeah I mean III think it
would be very weird if there were a
second planet full of life and to be
clear I don't think that life is likely
to be rare in the universe I just think
the universe is so big yeah yes so weird
and big the more weird and so weird and
big and we're made out of meat but
eleven of these meat sticks that we call
humans took the field for AFC Wimbledon
on Saturday how's that for a transition
did you say meat sticks yeah that's
basically what we are just sort of stick
shaped do what your phrase of the week
was but now I'm feeling like meat sticks
wealthy now like that you've made it you
made it more complicated for me so Henry
and I went to see the AFC Wimbledon game
against Oldham we had a really wonderful
time it was a really special day for
both of us and he had such a great time
and I can't recommend going and seeing a
Wimbledon game highly enough to people
who are even a little bit interested in
it but this was a very important game
because we are now down to the last few
games of the season and did his tight
tight tight at the bottom in the end it
was a 2-2 draw for Wimbledon two good
goals one scored by John Meads one in
which John Meads assisted Joe Piggot who
put the ball away very nicely in the
back of the net but unfortunately
Wimbledon gave up two goals gave up a
lead twice the second goal was scored in
the 73rd minute it was pretty
frustrating but a point is a point and
right now a point is not a bad result
three points would be better as I've
said repeatedly on this podcast every
year for the last 20 years 52 points has
been enough to stay up in Ligue 1 we
have 50 points with three games
remaining so we should only need by
historical standards two points to stay
up from the next three games however
it's looking like this season might be
the season where you need more than 52
points for the first time in two decades
in which case we would need probably to
win one of our last three games and
potentially win one and draw one it's
just so tight at the bottom right now
one and the development over the last
seven days is that the franchise
currently applying its trade in Milton
Keynes has functionally been relegated
from Ligue 1 and will spend next season
in the fourth tier of English football
Wow and happened it happened so now it's
it's just a matter of Wimbledon finding
a way to stay up and maybe we'll never
have to play those guys ever again that
would be a good outcome but yeah we've
got to win one of our last three games
the last game of the season is against
Barry who are
any relegated and so that should be a
winnable game but you never want it to
come down to the last game because all
kinds of weird things can happen when
people are under unspeakable pressure I
mean the you know it's just it's it's
stressful Hank I
I wake up in every morning the first
thing I do is look at the Ligue 1 table
and try to figure out all the ways that
things could go but at this point we
just need to play out the last couple
games well I mean the good thing was I
was paying attention to this that like
not nobody in the bottom of the table
won their game yeah and yeah so that
helps and it's like and and that you
drew is good yeah yeah yep I mean it's
possible that 50 points the the number
of points we have now will be enough
although I suspect not I suspect we need
let's just get a win this weekend
against Doncaster and just calm down I
mean this has been the most stressful 43
games stretch that I certainly I've had
as the sponsor and supporter of AFC
Wimbledon so I am I get those three
points get the points all right John
what is my was my phrase of the week is
it bag of pretzels nope it was not back
a pronoun what was it
Simone biles oh god of course a little
bit of an unusual phrase the week
suggested by Kimberly from the project
for awesome Thank You Kimberly for for
Simone biles wow that's a great
suggestion Kimberly congratulations I
worked it out I made it made it happen
John I think yours was a sigh Bowl
you're right that's what it was oh man I
I made up that whole story about
stealing my son's food I don't know how
else to work it in that was suggested by
an anonymous project for awesome donor
so thank you anonymous for donating the
project for awesome and I mean let's
face it I'm always bad at the phrase of
the week but especially when it's a word
I don't know how to pronounce
I also had meat sticks and shark attacks
as my alts yeah I mean meat sticks I was
trying to throw that in there at the
last second as a curveball but you
recognized it for exactly what it was
alright John what do we learn today well
we learned that if you come in to 499
bottles of homemade wine you need to
dispose of them immediately
you learned that snappy the t-rex can
protect you from the actual proper
danger that you face daily and we
learned that James Patterson gets to
publish on Mondays and we're all made
out of meat thank you for listening to
this week's podcast thanks to Hank for
podding with me and thanks to everybody
who supports our podcast on patreon at
patreon.com slash dear Hank and John we
really appreciate it we use that money
to fund crash course and scishow and the
art assignment the other stuff we do
here complexly so thank you and we're
gonna go record now our podcast for
patreon supporters this week in Ryan's
the worst eight minutes of your week we
should talk it up for John
Katherine listens to it and she says
it's good well I like to lower people's
expectations instead of raising them hey
got a problem with a right call will you
read the credits yeah if you want to
email us your questions please do that
that's how we that's how we make the
podcast happen it's dear Hank and nope
it's Hank and John at gmail.com no dear
and John and I are John Green and Hank
green on Twitter but less and less so
this podcast is edited by Nicholas
Jenkins it's produced by rosianna halse
rojas and sheridan Gibson our head of
community and communications is Victoria
bon giorno the music that you're hearing
now and the beginning of the episode and
during this weekend Ryan's is by the
great gunnarolla and as they say in our
hometown don't forget to be awesome
you
[Music]